[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
the distance between Heaven and Earth is
no greater than a thought
[Music]
even foul water will put out a fire
[Music]
the winner has many friends the loser
has good friends
[Music]
a fish sees the bait not the hook a man
sees the prophet not the danger
greed keeps men forever poor even the
abundance of this world will not make
them rich
[Music]
remember you have no companions but your
shadow
[Music]
it's difficult to take a wolf cub
without bringing in the whole pack
[Music]
an idiot can ask more questions than 10
wise men can answer
rich is he who has no debts fortunate is
he who has no handicap
conquer one with your hands a thousand
with your head
two bears in one cave will not end up
well
foreign
Ty is the source of success
while horses strong travel to see places
he who cleans up the dirt washes away
happiness
[Music]
he who wants to build high must dig deep
if the mind is clean the Fate is good
thank you
it is easier to catch an escaped horse
than to take back an escaped word